the girag an experience and then you
fought Connor when you were like 20 or
21 I danced 21 yeah 21 I think it's 23
or whatever I think he's 2 or 3 years
old
Jude is owning me yes I think if he was
24 then I was 20 tours on then 21 so
that was your last loss and then you
went on a crazy streak yeah you are a
crazy winning streak yeah yeah it was
crazy you know like what like when you
see that Connor doing stuff like I'm a
big believer in things have a reason you
know before that we had actually member
talking to you after the aftermath my
first one was Bermuda so knife uh
communities mm-hmm and I was a tough
fight I remember I ran into you at where
we fought MGM and I was and he was
leaving he was going back home to LA or
wherever he was going and I saw you at
the elevators he's like oh keep your
head up kid
so I thought you did I thought you did
enough and I was like yeah you be back
though for sure and then and then after
that we fought Conner and then those two
fights really meant a lot at that time
in my career cuz it just made me like
realize like how much I got a list I
really gotta buckle down I really had to
do do something I really had to find
something I didn't have a striking coach
I'm really yeah like I had my first
coach that started with like when I got
into UFC it was no longer and I I'm with
um I ended up doing jujitsu it around
his arse the coach I'm with now he's
been ever since UFC little bit before my
UFC fights too and then I never had a
striking cause for what Dustin and then
we went on for and women too so whatever
the one one five six seven my first
seven fights in the UFC so what did you
do for starting you wanna you really
want to know what I did yeah you know
the USC game I'll use Henin borough and
um and Jose Aldo and I'll do stuff with
them a black hole he had his works in
the game so my friend at the time Dustin
Kimura he would kind of hold mitts for
me and I'd be like look I tried this in
the game and it was working let's try it
and we did it I figured out from UFC
right you see the regular you see
getting the first ever using game
yeah what hit him bro watch the video
God played a video game and be like oh
look at this I tried combination I'll be
like oh yeah this kind of works so let's
try it
why not it was it got me that far that
is so ridiculous
Wow so then you realize you had to do
something different after the Bermudas
loss not the bermudez loss like the moon
is lost we was trying to find a striking
coach in this and that and in the corner
lost he was like yeah yeah we gotta get
this [ __ ] going you know my my my my
coach did Ryland right I was like man I
would pull somebody in and then he bring
in the guy I work with now I haven't
floors my striking coaches my striking
coach and AH and he lives on the islands
yeah that I did we all we all in one gym
now well together
Oscar yeah so it's like super easy now I
made a giant difference a huge
difference like big big dish what does
your brother say now Oh red the weight
of all time yeah nothing yeah I can't
say yeah let go yeah I never say hey man
you remember yeah I always yeah I'm not
gonna let you forget that God let you
forget that it's kind of hilarious right
it's like your younger brother telling
you he's gonna be a UFC fighter yeah he
turns out to be one of the all-time
greats and you're mocking them yeah he
said this is a said yeah good luck with
that is that you yeah you should start
you should start looking into colleges
or some type of state job I was like I
was like nah you just watch really wow
talk about like calling it but that's
one of those things like if someone
tells it to you like I'm gonna be a UFC
champion okay yeah one of my friends you
know like Micah Nakagawa like he he used
to train my alpha male because he went
to UC Davis yeah he got dropped he got
picked up from your favorite him because
the UC Davis and stuff and that's why
you can see rusty yeah he's a wrestler
yeah big-time wrestler and then I
remember the first time wrestling going
with him and I was in the UFC already
and I was in idea I was in the UFC
already and Chad was one of the top guys
you know in all done and Iraq I remember
my friend my friend told me does it come
more like oh yeah he channel alpha
military habla I woke up straight to him
I shook his hand I'm like I told him you
know what chad mendes ass right
I think he was like wait what I was like
yeah I probably will Chad Mendes ass
he's like okay and this is here after he
just taking my ass down like hundred
times in practice you know I mean like
he or or right before he did that in and
then he we would practice and he took me
now like a hundred times in practice you
know I don't know wrestling to good and
I still told him it and I started
talking like Chad Mendes eyes I'm gonna
beat up like this is this how life goes
you know I was like I'm probably I told
him I'm not probably at home I don't be
all day although I won't be the champ I
was like these guys can't date now you
touch man and you can ask him about the
story and he always told me like when I
actually happened here finally told me
like yeah max I was never going to tell
you but I thought you sucking same
different confidence
he's got put it on in the world you know
if you think you're gonna do something
go do it and go work hard I wasn't
scared of hard work but you've always
had this attitude though do you know
where you got it from
ah I don't like my grandpa you know I
guess it has to be from my grandpa you
know my grandpa he probably mad you know
he passed away when uh when I was eighth
grade but he probably be mad now I'm on
fire because he didn't want us he fight
he's a electrician so he just wanted us
to get a good job a great job family a
house and all that stuff but is this him
hard work you know like I remember
coming off coming home from practices or
or or school before you go out we had to
do all the chores whatever
every Saturday Sunday we wake up at 6
o'clock he had breakfast he had
breakfast made for us and we call clean
the yard before we could go do anything
else and he just had structure you know
and hard work and he's like if you want
say we had to pull weeds and he was one
of those guys that would find work out
of nothing like we doing one thing we'd
be done and it'd be done ahead of
schedule like okay perfect and he just
do this like no no this is not it
you know we could say nothing but we
gonna ask me if if we did but yeah I
think I was just my grandpa you know
like and it was just like sacrifices I
get high in high school but I what I did
was playing baseball and stuff like I
gave up all my my recesses my recess and
my and my lunches or my lunch we had
turned me at lunch and 15-minute recess
like to do my homework cuz all I wanted
to do was be a MLB player so when I went
out to practice right after baseball out
right
my left of school is finished I remember
just going on the field and not thinking
about going home like I do homework or I
got to do a project a lot of teachers
would help me out in school and stuff
and this and that that's how I got come
lolly like I'm not the smartest kid like
I figured out I hacked a lot of things
going to Kent getting in life I hacked a
lot of things like one of the things in
school I realized that you sit by one of
the smartest kids I used to sit by the
smartest kids every time I was in class
I'll sit by smarts kid accident for help
they're there help me willingly like be
okay help me help me help me and if I
get really got stuck today ah give me
that take my work do my work for me
perfect yeah I read like okay good I
just have to get like C's on top of my
my Tessa's to get the grades and I was
doing good you know boys and the money
so it is about hacking life I guess
[Applause]